jacob jiminez
is first max conrad what is up man
superhero geek what is up
malik james barnes in the chat what is
up
everybody legend everyone hey what's up
what is going on everybody
from holland i love holland
i love the netherlands and i
speak a little dutch express and [ __ ]
netherlands
hoot but i do speak it
giovanna what's up my dude um i need to
bring this over here there we go
and then let's do this
get a little bit smaller so i can see
everything and make sure i don't miss
anything
my cats are in the background there's
one
here let's rock it
and yes i named her after rocket raccoon
hi rockette
hi what you doing are we ready
hey what's up awesome123 it's going well
sorry let me check the audio
everything uh sounding alright
okay everything sounds good cool
what do we think is going to happen
today also i'm going to eat a protein
cookie real fast because i'm super
hungry
and uh and yeah so please bear with me
but what do we think is going to happen
in this episode i did my video today
about what i think is gonna happen
let me know what you guys think's gonna
happen in the chat
hey karen cox thanks so much
um
next next collab canadian lab next
collab
with the canadian lad oh i just wear
more of my glasses still they're blue
light glasses
um we talk a bit
um we talk a few times a month and he's
a really really cool dude and his
content is like amazing i love that guy
i love his channel um soon we've talked
about it
i know the zebo thing right
i can't believe they released that
that's so funny
i'm pretty sure i'm the first one to
hashtag releases emo cut
like like the second that report came
out
like i posted like a minute later
released this emoji hashtag releases
your cup and like it's on there
on twitter as proof like
it doesn't mean anything but i thought
it was cool
mr devon silly thank you i actually have
two cats
but um i don't think the other one's in
here
mr wick thank you yeah the canadian
lab's awesome
brantham pack gadar i'm sorry if i
pronounced that wrong
hey mr anderson what's going on the main
the main man the mvp uh sorry i didn't
get back to your email
i was thinking about it and then it by
the time
time came around we were here today um
but i'll email you back
you're doing a great job you're doing an
insane job so um i
appreciate everything you're doing john
cena's captain america
remember when that was a thing
when did that that was like that was
that was literally over a year ago
when we had reports of uh
john cena because john cena posted
something on his instagram he posted
like him with the shield right
he he did something like that let's see
is it out yet
sometimes release them early nope i
didn't even realize last episode was
called the power broker
whoops that's on me uh ethan i am good
thank you very much thank you very much
milo kelly hello
uh how many minutes until it's released
uh
i'm gonna say 19 but they have been
releasing it a little bit early
so ruby santana zemo dancing was pretty
hilarious
uh i can't believe marvel released a
video that's literally an hour of him
dancing
siva cr john walker fan nice nice nice
um any new collabs coming soon um
me and chris are starting a new show
um it's gonna be on my channel
and then we're gonna do a show on his
channel cause on his channel which is
also my channel
we're gonna do um like we talk about
like everything
so
i'm definitely willing to criticize
comic exposed uh
i like this one a lot better than one
division um
one division had some rough stuff but so
far i actually like the way this is
going
i think it's a good mix of
nons not not non-stop action because
there's more to
there's more to tv and movies and shows
than that
um i think there's a good amount of
emotionality in
involved i think it's tackling hard
subjects like the racism and stuff like
that
we'll see which way it goes i'm curious
to see how
john walker and battlestar i i do think
battlestar is gonna die i'm curious to
see how it's gonna go
um but i will admit i have liked
each like each new episode better than
the last one
but i do like this a lot better than i
liked wanda vision
i feel like one division if they and
it's easy to say looking back
if one division started the way it ended
it would have been a phenomenal show
but uh i i appreciated what they were
trying to do
and it was funny in its own sense but to
me that's just what it was it was funny
in the beginning
and they could they could have done
better with that but we got what we got
uh why did i get an operation
um i'm assuming you're talking about the
surgery surgery that i had
um so i was basically born with a
condition
um that affects my nerves and affects my
bones
and for like the past five years it's
been really really hard to walk
um i've actually been in a wheelchair
let's say like 40
of the time but i just don't post that
stuff nobody really cares about it right
so
not all people know that but uh
basically my doctors decided that it was
time to operate on my feet
and um i am still in a boot
but the cast has been off for i think
about two weeks now
uh but they're still really really sore
from the surgery because like they cut
into them so i don't know if they feel
better yet so we're just gonna have to
we're just gonna have to see wait on
that thanks for asking
uh i have seen thor supes his dog thor
he is very very cute
i have rocket who is giving herself a
bath right now what are you doing
don't look at me like
then yes she is named if if you didn't
catch that i did name my cat rocket
after rocket raccoon
my other cat's name is kyrie based off a
kairi from kingdom hearts
if anybody plays that hey
milo kelly thank you good luck for
future appreciate that
um chroma what if doctor doom makes an
appearance
um not in this show i
i'd be surprised uh i don't know
it just wouldn't make sense daniel salem
when is nova coming
i want to say if there's a chance that
he does get introduced soon i'm going to
say that's
with uh guardians of the galaxy or
door 11 thunder warren what if isaiah
bradley's the power broker
thoughts comic i suppose thank you so
much for that don't know again two times
thank you
that would kind of blow my mind um
that would be a good twist
i don't think it will happen because
it's hard because they don't stick with
comic lore um
that would be a really good twist that
would actually really really really
surprise me i would
be wondering what he was doing in his
home and not in madrapore
um but i because they said the power
broker is in like high end
i'm still i still think that sharon
carter's
excuse me i don't think she is the power
broker
well that that was my original theory
and she could because no one
or zuma hasn't seen the power broker he
said
but i would i would i would be shocked
if it was her
not shocked at all if she works for the
power broker
i would be stunned if isaiah bradley
was the power broker that would be crazy
you know and you could
make sense of that based off you know
like everything that was done to him
all the wrong that was done to him um
but i think he went
to you know in prison for years and
years and years and then he came out and
just kind of like lived in that house
that he's in right now
um i don't i don't think he would be in
like mad report or anything like that
it's a good thought though
people keep telling me to refresh it is
it out it's not out yet
not on me
red skull is power broker a lot of
people have um
kind of been saying that um
aj xyla old kappas power broker
sharon took super serum she was pretty
op
i i'm gonna i'm gonna give her that she
was pretty op
and since she knew yeah maybe she did
since she knew uh dr nagel
people keep saying it's out i i don't no
i don't have it yet it's not out for me
um no i don't like superman and lewis
more than falcon and winter soldier
daniel a video about my daily routine
i don't know if people would want to see
that
um i did do
i i did start like a personal channel
that was me just kind of like
unboxing things and i still have
stormbreaker to unbox
i just with my surgery and everything i
i don't um
i didn't i haven't had time to do it yet
uh but maybe i could do like a vlog on
there
um if enough people want to see it so uh
well chat's going kind of fast in my
just thought would you someday want to
collab with you one of the
things to do someday just a short theory
video yeah i actually want to like kind
of help out
smaller channels um that's kind of what
i've been
um doing with uh
well that's that was what i was planning
on doing with
my what the heck is it called podcast
um i wanted to kind of help smaller
youtubers grow
because i know what it's like to be a
small youtuber i was a small youtuber
once
um gladseller you think we can see old
captain american the show yeah
absolutely i
i don't think he's on the moon although
that would be pretty dang funny
if they just like did it as a joke or
something like he got to go to the moon
you know because he's such a such a
huge figure to the world um that you
know just like astronauts took him over
but i mean he's already been in space
so um yeah i i think we could definitely
see him though maybe at the end
zola uh yeah we could see dr zola
especially because it seemed like he's
pretty much
mastered putting himself into like
technology and stuff like that
solace mephisto hey winter soldier
thanks for that donut that's super chat
the mephista jokes were
funny that that kind of got out of hand
i i take my blame
in that um because i like i went into
that
mephisto hard like i will 100 admit to
that i
i went into that super hard but um i
still think mephisto is around in the
mcu especially because of that
that one scene in the the first loki
trailer where
we got um
uh it's like the stained glass in the
background and it's like a devil it's
like the devil like it's like literally
the devil so i'm like are
is marvel messing with us at this point
in time like what's the deal
do i think we can see red skull yeah
um but in a flashback
in a flashback not like for real
although the russo brothers did say
that red skull is free now to do
whatever he wanted
after they took the soul stone
so who knows uh the directors and the
writers don't always
match up um
so we'll see i see i see uh
oh it's out of town okay everyone's
saying that's not
all right the whole world is watching
yeah he's this is it
this is where it's going to blow up all
right we about to start
we're starting five four
three two
one
oh i have to check to make sure you
can't hear it
there's two people in there is the only
language these people understand
she's giving displaced people shelter
and medicine that kind of thing creates
loyalty man
you've literally tried it oh you can
totally hear it so we bet on someone
who's got a better hand
someone recreated the super soldier
serum you are assuming hydra has
something to do with
okay can you hear it now
okay cool cool can't hear it
that's the main thing
all right it's just a recap right now
guys you know i'll show you like
some stuff every now and then that's the
last thing they showed
all right let's see how we start here
let's make sure my my chat is okay or
everything's okay with my stream
looks like everything's good wow there's
a lot of watch parties happening right
now
wow
i don't see grace randall fun
all right here we go
that's magical
it's like oh no it's wakanda hold jeez
look we were kind of ready boys
six years ago in wakanda
dang
so she's she's saying all the code words
to activate the winter soldier
dang because because
it's not going to work he says
dang dang
dang oh that's so cool
oh it's showing him killing tony's
parents
becoming the winter soldier
homecoming
oh he's fighting it
he's fighting it
and he's getting it
you are free she says that's amazing
oh that's awesome
oh he's bawling i mean i would be too
oh no arm
now we're here
picking up right where we left off
she said sherry zemo killed tachaka
she's pissed that
wow
she said eight hours and we come for him
wow
this is pretty cool that's intense
all right done with the cookie almost
zemo lives a good life
eleven hundred three dead the flag
smasher bombing
flag smashers are getting worse
why am i not in full screen
now let me go this whole way without
being in full screen
haha
zemo's basically saying yo
you gotta
oh oh ho ho
that's pretty cool bucky said the serum
never corrupted
steve and zemo said touche but there's
never been another steve rogers wow
uh mr anderson for those like doing the
links and stuff like that you can just
leave it
oh yeah flag smashers are on the run
they're listening to the radio
just merchant woof woof
what you doing rocket
they're listening to the radio they're
just talking about the flag smashers
right now
uh maybe there's sean that's a definite
possibility oh
as you know this coat is so cool
coat is epic
hey thank you michael thomas hey lord
savage
no problem so they're they're at the
i can't remember what they called it
where uh mama dania was
was dying at where the flag smashers
were where i believe the flag smashers
are still around
oh everyone's running from him
liar you've you've heard oh they're
about something's about to go down
yeah black smasher symbol right there
oh everybody's running
everybody's running from like
they recognize sam and bucky
they're they're basically running away
when they see him
i know right mr anderson i want his coat
for sure
internationally displaced persons
we don't trust outsiders
i'm talking about the grc uh dang they
promised to send more supplies
that was six months ago
he said he knows who he is but he can't
trust him and he took everybody and left
dude zemo's so cool
zima's gonna give him candy
gosh he's so menacing
oh a bunch of candy for the little kids
gosh he most menacing and he's cool
oh it was his son's favorite
i seem so smooth
hey patrick r good morning from germany
good night from america it's like 1am
for me so
good morning good night
they're like what the heck is zemo's
doing but zemo's getting stuff done
with the awesome coat
oh he said
they gave a bunch of candy to the kids
and told the kids that falcon
and winter soldier are bad
what's about to happen
this is a great show so far
sam is talking about how the world was
kind of united
during the blip to five years
they were all helping each other
andrew haiti sometimes they start like
10 minutes early
oh zemo isn't betraying them he told him
about the funeral
haha pass unwritten not for sure
thank you for that uh super chat
appreciate it and it's
oh snap oh bucky's in his
face that actually took me by surprise
dang he just took a glass that was in
zemo's hand he threw against the wallet
that's over by surprise holy wow that
actually kind of like made me
hey sure carter
she's back
she just says she may have may or may
not have access to a satellite or two
he just she just said the power broker
went crazy
when he found out i think she said he
when he found out that she when he found
out that the
the doctor was dead
well there's at a grave
at a specific grave oh look at that wow
that is secretive
there's a bag excuse me
sorry
oh the serum
she said do you think they're making a
mistake you think we're making a mistake
making more of us
rock it hey
wow he said i didn't think there could
be another captain america until i met
you
and he's talking about carly
saying the world is the world used to be
good and bad but it's more complicated
now
so today's heroes don't have the luxury
of keeping their hands clean
they're talking bad about the shield oh
she said the shield should be destroyed
because it's as it's a monument to a
old era
is anybody gonna tell us who mama dania
is
oh look at this oh they're back
i think two avengers can walk around
without drawing attention
this is intense
he's trying to stop them
buildings
oh hoskins sided with sam said if you
could talk her down might be worth a try
so interesting so the little girl is the
one that's going to lead zemo but
zemo told her that every
that that falcon and bucky and them were
bad he just gave her 500
i don't know the currency that in that
country but something
gosh she knows a baller
john walker is so confused
gosh she was such a baller
uh since when did a fully male marvel
fan become a k-pop fan
i love k-pop it's like all i listen to
blackpink twice got7
itsy
straight kids i listen to a lot of k-pop
it's pretty much
all i listen to there's a k-pop
thing here too that's my
all right so here's her funeral
this is interesting there
talking about mama dania
she clothed me fed me loved me they're
telling us a lot about her
she saw a falcon and she freaked out
she sees falcon
but she's continuing
the struggle is what brings us together
the people who have nothing in common
oh she sees him she sees she sees falcon
oh they're all paying their respects
they don't really talk about who she is
i wonder if they're going to talk about
her more she just kind of says that you
know she took everybody in
and stuff like that um
it is starting for those asking where
we're at
oh look at these guys just staring at
the shield
oh he's got a headache he totally took
some serum or something he had to of
oh dude battlestar's gonna die i know it
i feel it coming
and that's kind of a bummer because i
actually like his character he talks
since the freaking john walker
all right here we go carly and sam
the smiling tiger he says i just want to
talk
ugh
sam says i understand you and your
frustration your helplessness
there doesn't need to be a war hmm
she says you're brilliant or hopelessly
optimistic that's pretty good
say can i be both no john walker you
chill
you chill chill john walker you're gonna
blow it all
john's losing it he's saying don't don't
do that don't patronize me
he's losing it he's just gonna run right
now yep oh
oh he's going in
come on you're not gonna beat a winter
soldier oh
he says john walker just said do you
really want your partner's blood on your
hands
yeah john walker is having a mental
breakdown
this is an interesting conversation
he said you have more serum and you're
going to increase your army
and you're killing innocent people
there you go
ooh sam says i'm not your enemy i agree
with your fight
i just can't he said i agree with your
fight i just can't
do it the way you're fighting it i can't
agree with that
oh freaking john walker comes
oh snap
is that bucky yeah that's bucky going
after her dang
oh gosh everybody's trying to freaking
john walker screwed everything up who
was in handcuffs zemo oh he's gone
they just showed a pair of uh empty
handcuffs zemo's gone
oh this is the this is like the
warehouse place where the photo was
taken i think
oh no i think battlestar is about to eat
it
i really do i really really really
really really do
no oh zebo shot her
he's going at it dang zemo means
business
oh there's the serum she dropped all the
serum
what is he going to do with the serum
that's all on the ground oh he shot her
is he going to step on it stop about it
all zemo
she's about to attack you hard
what you gonna do
oh oh all the serum
zima just stepped on all that serum oh
who's fighting him now
oh captain america shield
this is uh interesting
he just knocked out zemo oh there's one
left oh he's gonna take it
oh he's gonna take it
yeah he's gonna take it he's starting to
feel inferior
to the uh he's starting to feel inferior
to the old captain america
so he's gonna take the serum
he's got in his hand and in the pocket
look at that
there's lamar
this dude about to die maybe not
she said all the vials have been
destroyed
dang did my stream freeze i don't think
so
i'm still on right
i'm still okay
who's that who's that behind her oh no
it's a guy it's the guy
thank you zak
appreciate that
sorry how many minutes left let me tell
you
uh 25.
so 20 because of the credits right
the power broker texted them said i want
the serum back or i'll find you
and end them and in you she said i'll
deal with the power broker
so 51 oh we separate them
we oh she just said we separate them and
we kill captain america
someone's gonna die
oh he says were you ever offered the
serum sam said no
if you had been would you have taken it
sam says no
see seema got freaking hit in the head
he's with that shield
is super soldiers cannot be allowed to
exist
oh sam isn't that how gods talk
what about bucky
he says blood isn't always a solution
bucky says something's not right about
walker
oh there he is
john says let's go zemo's going to jail
and they're saying nah
oh john walker said i'll put down the
shield should we put down the shield to
make it fair
oh oh look who's here oh dang oh it's
supposed to intense
the what contents are here
time's up
oh john walker she don't care bro
she do not care
let's put down the pointy sticks and
we'll talk this through
the door melange the door of elijah
don't touch her no that's not gonna be
good dude come on man
oh oh snap this is not going to be good
this is just not going to be good
see this is drinking
oh snap oh snap she's got him
we should do something
he's taunting jonah as he's getting his
butt kicked
dude they are destroying them
io
no don't kill lamar don't kill amar
no don't kill amar don't kill sam either
by
zemo peace
lock the door
holy crap good throw
oh stab she just deactivated his arm
whoa
i don't know what she just said
i think she said bathroom
yeah the wakandans just kicked john
walker's butt
oh she kicked it up and grabbed it look
at that
that's cool dang
she gave it back to him i think bucky's
arm got ripped off that's crazy
sam says did she know they could do that
and bucky says no
well dang
oh john walker's losing it
he says they weren't even super soldiers
and he got his butt kicked oh
yeah john walker is about to take that
serum and he's losing it
john walker knows he can't john walker
knows he has no chance he has no chance
io just and the door milaje
just killed it
i can't believe you pulled out javo
that's hilarious
zemo escaped
escape through the drain
oh people are asking for his autographed
i believe he wants to be a good guy he's
got a headache
does he get a headache
he says i even got a battlestar logo i
draw with people ask for his autograph
if you have a chance to take the serum
would you do it he said hells yeah
john walker would you be worried about
how it might change you um
power just makes a person more of them
themselves carl and steve that's a good
point
he says you've already got three medals
of honor
and you make the right decisions in
battle i don't think he already took the
serum i think he's
contemplating
oh he said the things we did in
afghanistan
would not be awarded medals
oh they're saying imagine how many lives
you could have saved when they were in
the military if they had that serum
dang he's gonna take it
yeah he's gonna take it who do we got
here this is carly
who is this oh it's sam's sister
oh no
she's she's talking
flag smashes are talking to sam's sister
oh she says i'm trying to figure out if
i need to kill your brother
i like you sarah you remind me
carly says i need to meet with sam alone
i'm gonna send you the coordinates
to pass along
she just dropped her child's name
children's names
stuff needs to happen like right now
she carly called his sister threaten his
nephews
go somewhere safe and only pay cash dang
dang
rooftop north plaza now come alone
some something's gonna happen buggy says
i'm coming with you
but sam said she said come along oh they
suited up boys
he's yelling
it's gonna be interesting does
battlestar die
i see you didn't come alone
carly says if i were to kill you it'd be
meaningless
oh she's asking sam to join her or let
her go
meanwhile sharon carter is doing
something
oh snap up they fight now
here we go
well he's gone
what is happening here what the heck is
this guy doing
you are blowing it dude
captain america with a gun look at that
he only really saw that in the first
captain movie
that shield is shiny
oh are you about to take the serum now
i was calling for lamar and lamar has
been to
i bet you lamar's been to oh no no no no
dude he's gonna die they found he just
found lamar's gun
dude they they killed him they killed
him they had to have killed lamar
dude did they kill him not yet they're
going to
oh punch
said time up dude they're gonna oh no
they're gonna kill him the martian it
died
kill walker i hate him
at least don't hang him
they said time up holy crap
all right here he goes the new cap
against some super soldiers
he don't stand a chance we threw the
shield
i threw it hard
please don't kill please don't kill them
are
kill walker i don't care if he dies i
like i like
i like battle star
here's falcon oh
oh dang walker's handling himself
did walker walker took this he took the
serum walker took the serum
oh yeah totally
he said they got lamar oh no they're
gonna waterboard him
or they have waterboarded him or
something
no he's tied up is that gas please don't
be gassed don't kill him
walker took the serum though for sure
come on lamar he's trying to get out
he's trying to get like a knife or
something yeah come on get out of there
dude
here's bucky balls
this is a hooded figure do you know who
it is that's just a flag smasher
yeah walker took the serum already he's
a super soldier now
how did he how could he inject it though
just like drink it or something i mean
bucky said stay there after he kicked
this guy's face in
uh oh
oh walker with the cat moves ooh falcon
when the falcon moves
walker what's with all the knives that's
funny
come on lamar get out of there yeah come
on
come on dude but like run away don't go
fight
run away you're gonna die dude you need
to run
ah this is actually pretty cool oh
there's that scene
dude sam knows how to use his suit
this is pretty cool
she's going to kill him she's going to
kill him but
oh but lamar jumps in the way he's going
to die
oh no not oh no lamar no
i knew it i freaking knew it
oh i freaking knew it
now everyone freaking he's oh my gosh
why him you better do something now john
walker
here he goes here we go do it just like
captain
oh he's a super soldier all right and
he's about to rip someone's head off
that guy your head's gone
throw that shield down at him avenge
your friend oh this guy's dead this
guy's so dead
vlogger is about to freaking oh
oh gosh oh here it is this is gonna
destroy him
oh no
here we go oh he's dead oh
oh no everyone's filming oh
oh no
oh
oh no he just killed him dead
everyone's filming everyone's filming
and carly's watching everyone's filming
let's watch captain america brutally
murder this guy
then he sees it he sees everybody
looking and filming
oh that's crazy look at that blood on it
is that it oh my gosh what an
ending
oh man
i called in my video today if you guys
watch the video i did
this like exactly i knew this was gonna
happen i knew this was gonna happen
let's see if there's a post credit i
think one division episode something is
when they start doing post credits
ever said something's a real episode
right
holy crap wow what
oh i'm so pissed
i'm so pissed
let's get in the zoom oh i passed
holy crap guys that was like
oh i mean
wow guys that was um
i'm glad he killed him because they
killed lamar
um and i i knew
i what's up chris cosmic culture in the
chat go follow cosmic culture
i knew they were going to freaking do it
i literally my whole video today
i basically just said what i basically
said what happened
and i freaking knew it because of that
picture with the blood on it i knew it
was either lamar's blood
or it was freaking
wow
what an episode i it wasn't my favorite
episode
uh but that wow what an intense
ending and the wakandan part was really
really cool like uh
i definitely give it that that that what
kind of part was was pretty insane
that's
freaking crazy though let's see where
supes is at with his
watch party uh we'll get everybody
up in the chat here i think the episode
was like 50 minutes
long
uh no they did a few post credit scenes
uh i think they started at like episode
six for one division
so oh this camera angle is not going to
work
hold on let's do this and please
wait let's get everything ready for the
zoom
chat um
is everything working gonna meet up with
soups and bread
here we go
question
i was gonna say what an episode to come
oh my god okay
so soups i did a video today that
described exactly what just happened
bro legit i i legit i saw your tick tock
too
yeah i saw it i put i put i did i put it
all out into the universe
yeah no we basically said the same thing
we talked about that picture because i
saw your tick tock yeah i did the same i
did the same exact video on it i mean
holy crap we we called it
like and i'm pissed
i'm i'm pissed that lamar died yeah
dude lamar was an awesome character he
was a casualty for john walker oh
exactly he was a casualty for john
walker and
okay john walker took the serum
obviously you know
we know that walker took the serum so
did he take it already though oh for
sure you don't bend the metal
yeah he bent the metal pole he jumped
out the window landed on the car
through a wall yeah like i was like yo
like how's he doing this stuff no
possible way yeah he was holding his own
against the super soldiers because even
before you know he was
you know when uh when the wakandans beat
him up
he was straight up like they weren't
even super soldiers like
you know he was
that was insane man oh my gosh
public execution yeah with everybody
watching it
with public execution oh what am i doing
sorry i gotta shoot this guy
yo
[Music]
dude he's cracked
oh my gosh bro i don't even like that
i really really really did not want
battle star today yeah he was talking
about his signature now we're never
going to get to see you
i know yo but how much more important
was that conversation
with that he had with john oh well yeah
he's the one that convinced him to take
it
why aren't you let me adjust this
what's an episode bro
and guys if we're watching this live
stream go right now and sub to brad or
lambert on youtube warren brad's live
yeah i stopped by and i was like let's
go guys go sub to brad
lambert on youtube he's live on youtube
let's let's get him to a thousand subs
go spam him right now go spam brad
go get him watching his live stream go
spam in the chat
john walker's the goat john walker's the
goat go spam it in the chat i'm looking
at the chat
randy bernstein thanks for that super
chat uh yeah sam might get in the last
episode which
i'm kind of upset about i hope he gets
it uh i hope he gets it sooner than that
but yeah we did see him practicing with
it
man what an episode on youtube
let's uh youtube
where is the brad i don't see him
he's live right yeah yeah yo yo warren
tell your stream so go spam him in the
chat yeah hey guys get him can we
get him to a thousand subscribers brad r
lambert this dude right here the guy
that's always in our uh
the guy that's always in our uh our
watch let's get him to a thousand subs
a thousand subs right now he's 30 away
he's 30 away guys if we can get brad
over a thousand one over a thousand
let's go
oh no what happened he's having
technical difficulties
them anyways anyways let's get brad to a
thousand subscribers
let's get brad over a thousand
it's there oh nine eight nine
nine eight nine
bro let's go 1k
keep it going keep going keep it going
keep it going guys
spam john walker's the goat in brad's
chat 1.01
keep it going he's already he's not even
here
brad come back
bro let's go yeah that's awesome keep
subscribing john walker's the goat in
his chat let's
keep on
keep on subbing keep on subbing john
walker's the goat
well we've got something to brag let's
go let's keep it rolling
yeah brad's got so much in the works
over here on youtube one point
let's keep on subbing to him yeah item
up right now these two guys with
trending
they're trending series it's freaking
awesome
sub to brad our library on youtube right
now let's let's get this man right
straight up straight up let's get this
man
right look we almost got until one point
one
no he's out point one no no oh yeah yeah
almost 1.1 oh yeah
already let's do it bros let's let's get
him to 1.1 right now
uh-huh and so we should have seen an
r-rated kill shot but marvel doesn't
have the balls
well you got to keep it you know they
they want to like appeal to like
a lot of people and you can't have it
like yeah
it's all disney applause you know
you guys go to brad lambert on youtube
he's at 1.06 let's get him to 1.1
he's uh he's always he's the goat 1.07
he's uh he's the one that's always on
the chat with me and supes
chris yes this is uh this is the
community
is what it is right here coming together
the fam
coming together for the greater good
1.07
well jeez dude
okay okay warren hi bro
where do they go for now from here now
yeah i um
like what so the question i think
now is well two questions one
where the heck zemo go oh yeah that's
right
right yeah right zuma what did they say
i can't believe you el chapo did it
so zuma's gone went through under uh
the bathtub there's drain there
and you know it kind of seemed like
he was really like playing nice for a
long time
right i mean because remember uh last
episode
he like escaped after he killed dr nagel
but he came back
he came back like twice so it really
does seem like he's playing nice
and he just had to leave because you
know freaking john walker screwed every
john walker just needed to chill
out and it would have been okay
you know what i mean like it would have
been okay if john walker just
chilled lamar would still be alive
dude yeah i'm just chill then let sam
talk to her bro
like first of all bro i thought it was
so awesome
to see just the sam skill
sam skill and dealing with people like
this because that's all he did
before winter soldier yeah
helping soldiers just like carly with
ptsd that are
struggling mentally and bro he was like
you just like with the way that
conversation was going between them soup
like you could see the way he was just
like
he was just outsmarting outsmarting her
in the conversation so like that she
sounded crazy
yeah she was double guessing everything
yeah because what did she say she was
like you're either
a genius or or some i can't remember
what it was
uh optimistic like insanely optimistic
or early
not naively optimistic or something and
he's like gonna be a little bit about
like knowing exactly what to say
like dude he's one with the words he
really is and i gotta say though
the whole entire episode i'm sitting
there like zemo is like such a freaking
cool guy is he was like five steps ahead
of him dude zemo is
freaking awesome like going like with
this freaking
coat just how he like presents himself
you know he's like oh i'm a baron you
know this is like my family's royalty
before you know you
douches came and just giving the candy
to the kids and finding out everything
they'd be so lost without zero and
i mean dang yo i'm here
for a gaming sense in a 20 super chat
they said next episode i'm calling it
sam gets the show
brad is back he's back brad is back
he's back on stream guys let's get him
to 1.1 k
he's at 1.09
1.1 let's get him to 1.1 appreciate you
[Music]
spam him right now
so is he is he gonna be joining us
uh no no he's not gonna be joining us
because he's cause his computer
his his laptop can't handle all of it oh
gosh you gotta get
good what'd you guys think cool guys
let's get brought to one point one right
now
one point one on youtube is he there and
nope not yet
we're almost there guys brad our lambert
on youtube go sub to this man
boom he's just hit let's go there you go
yeah a lot of
uh uh
thank you the newbie pro official um
yeah a lot of a lot of people are really
shocked with that ending
um uh out of that behind the scenes set
video bro
yeah i was gonna say you know i posted
that set video today in my video i
posted the picture of him with the
bloody shield
and i'm sitting there going like the
bloody shield is definitely because
because you know john walker just
decapitated that person
jeff aquino thanks for that super chat
i'm glad john walker screwed up sam will
take the shield back or even bucky i
don't like the second hand cap i don't
think anybody
really does and you know what supes and
chris
there was one split second when he was
talking to lamar when i thought
okay you're still trying to hold on to a
little bit of good
you know what i mean when he was sitting
there like you know would you take it
and he's like but you know
you're not scared about what it would do
to you and stuff like that and then
and then lamar was even like man you get
threes you know stars and like all the
stuff
you know and he's even sitting there
like being almost like being like humble
about it when he's sitting there going
like
yeah but like the things we did and then
he's like imagine what we could have
done
you know if we had to so i'm sitting
there like you know what i believe he
wants to do good
and i don't like honestly like if
somebody was like
killed my partner in crime right my pic
i go kill them i'd go i go crazy i want
to do it in public in front of a million
people with cell phones
but i guess when you're that like this
is you know what this is
this is freaking star-lord infinity war
yeah yeah john walk pretty much this is
star-lord in infinity war pretty much
bro and and bro what a i look i already
called it like i knew
when he was having that conversation
with lamar that that was probably going
to be his last conversation with lamar
and
it was going to be so significant
because that conversation was so
significant i mean
they're talking about the serum and
right before we see john
just lose it and turn and kill that man
we we have this conversation where he's
talking about how
everything they did in afghanistan all
of those medals all those awards that he
received
none of that felt right he never felt
deserving of those medals and those
awards
but being captain america is the first
thing in his life that felt right
yeah he felt like he could make a
difference and i think this episode
showed his struggle of not being steve
rogers yeah not not
you know we saw him several times like
just grab his head or like you know the
top of his nose in frustration
and and you just could see how much he
is like
i'm not steve i'm not a strong blah blah
blah and then when
you know when the condon freaking woman
kicked his butt he's like
you can tell he's like those weren't
even super soldiers
like i i'm captain america
yeah it destroyed him rushed him yeah
because he just wants to be i genuinely
believe he wants to be a really good
person he's just screwing up right he's
just screwing up a lot
i genuinely believe he wants to be a
good captain america like right that's
his thing like he wants to do good
but he can't because he's well he wasn't
a super soldier now he is
but he talked about what does that do to
you
you know what i mean what is that dude
yeah i think
um dude like now he's not gonna stop
he's not gonna stop
until he gets to carly and guess what
sam and bucky are gonna are gonna stick
up for carly and they're gonna get in
his way and that's where it's gonna get
bloody
that's where it's gonna get crazy yeah
and now he's about nothing to lose
because like nothing bro there's no one
he has no one and he's outed like that
that stuff's going all over the internet
like he's gonna like it's just gonna be
he's got his cap yeah there's no way the
government can put up with that no he's
just going to run
and at some point yeah and at some point
in time sam or bucky are going to take
the shield from him and just say you
know you're not steve
and he might willingly give it up he
might say i'm not
so yeah i don't know us agent baby
shout out thunderbolt where's
thunderbolt when you need him
yo that's another thing too bro whole
episode again
power broker just chilling in the
background just chilling in the
background in the background
sinha thank you for that super chat this
is the first time the cap shield had
blood on it camera angle was on purpose
oh for sure
oh for sure oh for sure i hope so next
episode i hope that's i hope the power
broker is the mystery character next
episode
yeah that's we do have to remember that
the mystery character is coming next
episode
and so i believe
sharon did say he right yeah
so it's a guy but she's clearly
connected with him some
somehow which is what i which is what i
really thought um
yeah yeah dang yeah and then we know
they that that they reunite with zemo
because of the oh for sure you know the
shot the shot of bucky with the gun
releasing the bullets yeah that's going
to probably be at the memorial
that he goes and visits the zocovia
memorial because he's going to go visit
obviously that's like his family right
so i i think zemo's story
is very very well done in the mcu
um very well done because it comes from
a side that you can actually like
really care about and relate to him with
because you know he lost his family
yeah and what a way to bring him back
for a show like this where oh yeah
perfect he's
he's he's pretty much the same as carly
oh i mean yeah carly's not carly's not
me may not be
as you know smart and witty as emo but
they're both coming from the same place
of hurt
camel robinson walker's conversation
about taking consumers contracts to sans
conversation about taking serum thank
you camille for that super chat and i
totally agree
release the r rated cut that's funny um
ashley mcgaha thank you for that super
chat i love when she just took off his
arm that was so cool wasn't it
that was so cool wasn't it yeah yeah i
think sam is obviously way above
john walker obviously you know which is
good because john's losing it
um thank you for that super chat spider
guy
alex that was brutal but good episode
yeah i agree it was pretty freaking cool
it was pretty freaking cool bradley
jones i know it's been rumored for years
now but do you think we'll get a red
hole came in the last episode
uh it might be teased i don't think
we'll see it
but but i do think thunderbolts are
coming and i do think
uh red hulk has come in armando thank
you for that super chat old man
captain's power broker he got defected
haha
it's a cool theory to think about but i
don't think so that would be really
i mean if they did that that would be
insane like literally insane
so that would be super exciting at the
end of going that direction for sure
i mean it was brutal i mean that was
but you know what's interesting i was
waiting i was waiting to hear and maybe
he did kind of like say he said some few
words but i believe in the leaked video
he's like look at me as he's like
bashing his face in
i wonder i was kind of expecting that
but they
he said something else you know i'm
gonna go back and re-watch it obviously
but that's crazy bro
it was a good episode wasn't my favorite
but it was a really good episode
um so i got a pretty decent question
from jake who dropped the five dollar
super chat again appreciations
he wants to know what becomes of john
walker
does he die does he become a good guy a
bad guy he's taking the super soldier
serum now
he can't just disappear right
so something has to become of him what
do you guys think happens let's soup
nailed it u.s agent go ahead subs take
it away
yeah us agent like uh now he just
completely
the the us government is going to throw
the sky to the to the dumpster after
this
king j thanks for that super chat do i
think what kind of people kill zima no i
don't think zemo is going to die
i don't think he was gonna play eric
morgan thanks for the super chat how
nice of them to keep
the old black guys surviving the movie
troop alive
i'm just kidding someone i mean he was
was not the first one to die because
carly killed a bunch of people but yeah
and i they might i mean this this this
show addresses racism so i wonder
what will happen about that
looks like i got them all if i forgot
them i apologize
you think you took the serum yeah john
walker john walker for sure took the
serum
you can't jump out of a window land on a
car like that he like destroyed the car
when he fell on it
and oh yeah he bit that through a wall
well and when he
like chris said he bent that pole and
even the super soldier was like oh crap
or
you know whatever you said yeah and at
that moment you're just like i wonder
how he took it though right did you just
have a syringe on him
like yeah like
what is that he's thinking with
government he's got whatever he needs
that's why they didn't show it
i think he took it in between
i think he took it after lamar got taken
real fast somehow
hey brad how you doing i don't know is
brad in the chat
yeah it looks like we got brad in here
hey and jerome jones thank you so much
for that five dollar chip chat
i'm not hearing brad does anybody hear
him what's up boys
hey hey mr 1k
hey you know trying to be cool like you
guys
wait hold on hold on hey mr one point 12
k 1.12 okay
what's up dude almost almost appreciate
the love guys we're having fun today so
thank you for that
the goat community is awesome it is it
really is what you think man let's hear
your thoughts
what a fantastic episode that that that
ending man
yeah i did not expect them to end the
episode on that note
but what a statement that was it was a
great it was a it was a great way to end
that episode
100 i was kind of hoping for an end
credit scene but
i know i looked for it too yeah because
when did one division start doing it
like episode six
seven it was about about halfway through
yeah yeah the final three episodes final
three right so episode seven that's what
that's what i thought so that's why i
thought we might go in today
but yeah guys we got we got two left
yeah that's crazy okay
uh how did sharon know the flag smashers
found john walker was she tracking them
because she is powerbucker
kazmir thank you so much for that um i
don't think she is the power broker
but i think she has like deep
connections with him
uh she's very well connected obviously
uh so yeah jerome jones thank you again
for that superhero
or for that super chat you think zemo
will kill john walker
at the end now that he has to serum that
would be a pretty good
ending not going to lie that would be
pretty crazy
did i just did i just lose you guys
hello
was talking and then he stopped did i
miss something
no no yeah he's there oh here's a here's
a good
uh question that i like um from jerome
jones thank you super chat
you think zemo will kill john walker at
the end now that john walker
has the serum and is a super soldier i
like that
yes that's pretty good 100 percent
jerome jones
that's not no way joe walker dies in
this show you don't think
dude they're not going to throw away his
character like that he has a future in
the mcu
i don't know marvel throws away
characters a lot i could see him throw
them okay
so let's talk about that marvel does
throw away characters
they have an abundance of characters but
i'm using a character
yeah i don't i don't know if they will
kill john
um i agree that marvel throws characters
away i'm still hoping ultron returns
but uh but uh
but yeah uh i think john stays alive
i do i um i think it's
i think it's too good of a character to
throw away and i think moving forward
it might it might be like a character
that pops up in you know maybe an actual
new captain america movie or show or
something like that you know what i mean
like
um because i for one hope they you know
either sam
becomes a new captain america something
like that i hope we do get a new cap i
hope sam does get the shield
right i hope that's him um
and maybe maybe he's always there you
know he could even go on to
kind of become a character like zemo
right where he's kind of like in jail or
something like that
and he goes to him and he's like you
once you know believed in what the
shield stood for and you wanted to do
good and like all this stuff like that
like i'm you know here's your chance to
do it again
you know we need everybody we can get
for you know a mission or something like
that you know
there's a lot of potential with them and
i think it would be a shame if they
killed him
oh yeah dude for sure like there's so
much more they could do with his
character and
again with the way they focused on him
and given him so much backstory in the
show
it would be a total waste to throw him
away but um lincoln green sent in a
super chat and asked
um do you think we're going to see
chadwick boseman next episode
as a cameo because um i don't think
we're going to see chadwick
i don't i don't think we're going to see
chadwick at all i don't think we're
going to see challah but
af because zemo is still at large
the wakandans aren't backing down bro
like there's no way the
the continents just said all right
scene was i guess that was crazy so cool
it was crazy cool
dude hold up hold up boys cold open
bucking wakanda
oh yeah that was so cool that was this
really was a good episode the music
the music yes bro i i was getting chills
bro
and the fact that this again this is the
great thing about the disney plush shows
the way they fill in the gaps bro like
last episode
got some super chats to talk about here
holly larson thank you so much for that
super chat could john walker become like
red skull he was bleeding like red skull
in the first cat movie probably not
exactly like him
but maybe um i don't think nearly as
serious but that's a great thought
vinnie thank you for that super chat why
does it seem like zema doesn't want to
kill bucky
would you be considering he's a super
soldier because i think he may be
thinking he's like steve right because
he was like
he said touche to steve um so i think he
believes that they might be good
but doggo 73 thank you so much for that
super chat what are the odds that
battlestar is alive great ops 2.
you know i thought he might have been
when when they showed him again
when when when he was like laying there
on the on the pl
on the pole and i thought like oh he's
going to move he's going to be live
he might be alive who knows i really
hope he is alive
i really really really hope he's live
yeah i did too i i thought they were
going to show sherry too
so one thing i do want to talk about
though is um
because i got a super chat here that's
where to go
uh could uh where'd it go
uh why does it seem like zemo doesn't
want to kill bucky weird to me
considering he's a super soldier we had
that pretty cool scene
where um bucky was it
was it sam or bucky nose bucky who was
talking to zemo
and he was like you know
super soldiers are bad he's like no
steve was good blah blah blah and then
zemo was like touche
i was like oh and he goes but they're
but no one is steve rogers and i'm like
dang that and that's like a
that was like a big point of this
episode like john walker's not steve
rogers right
yeah you know these other super soldiers
aren't steve rogers you know a big
conversation about
what happens when you take the serum
does does it turn you bad you know and
you know what's really weird
is like i used to before i got like
really really hurt and sick i used to do
competitive bodybuilding
and my coach used to always try to get
me to steroids and i always said no
never took steroids and i always been
like you know
don't steroids make you like super mean
and angry all the time and he used to
say like
they just bring whatever you are out
more so if you're a
douche and a jerk you're gonna be a
bigger douche and a jerk and that's
almost kind of like
what they were saying with the serum
right like if
you're a good person becomes great bad
becomes worse there you go
yes uh king jay thanks for super chat
what if power brokers general ross
i hope so i hope you
started thunderbolts i hope so i feel
like that's why they
i feel like that's why they're saving
that character because i feel like it's
someone we know
it's uh it's paw patrol
look at episode five he had white vision
returns he's been the power broker the
whole time
yeah for the past for the past
four and a half months white vision like
started his own gang and started
creating super soldiers
there are the crazy theories we've been
waiting for there we go
yo dude i'm about to go hold up i legit
they
predicted this entire episode so
everyone that still spans from pistol
in my comment section can suck it
i just embrace it i'm like yeah and i
totally it would have been better for me
wasn't it should've went with my
theories
that's what i said look we're not gonna
be right that's the whole fun of
everything we're not gonna be right
about everything right but it's fun to
to think about we are right like today
well today was 100
right about everything happened you go
watch my video the latest video that i
did
same with soups go watch this video
totally called
everything that happened like literally
every single thing that happened
so jeez that was that was insane
uh ritwik jahan i'm sorry if i
did not pronounce it right but thank you
so much cat made the same move with the
shield in civil war but then it killed
tony he hit him in the arc reactor
walking in the same move the seat and
kill the guy good becomes great bab
comes worse 100
here's a um cool super chat from
ritwik johann he says cap made the same
move with the shield in civil war
but didn't kill tony he hit him in the
arc reactor but walker made the same
move
and as steve but he killed the guy good
becomes great bad becomes worse
to the face bro yo and speaking of
throwing away characters
rip taurus bro yeah where the heck did
he go
rip torres um
sean baker thank you so much for that
super chat ross is power broker i
i hope i really hope that's what i would
really
really really really hope
sherry silver fox thank you for that
super chat what if steve rogers power
broker yeah i've heard that a few times
and i think that would just be
such a weird twist and it would make
me question a lot and i think it would
make
the whole entire mcu question a lot
it would just it would almost be
unnecessary to me
um and and a bummer to me if that would
happen
as well you know money and power and all
of those cool things that come with
that kind of prerogative it does kind of
make you who you really are so if you're
a bad person
power will make you a more bad person if
you're and we've seen that with
with john walker throughout the whole
season he's kind of got a hot head
and he kind of does have these anger
snaps so taking the serum
and having that power just made him have
a little bit more and it was a little
bit more evident and you know he ended
up killing a guy in the street
so i thought that was kind of a cool
little connection that they did there
well and and who just said it so
it was one of my chat said it noah
navarette never
tastes ever just if i didn't pronounce
that right um
lamar was kind of walker's compass like
right he stepped in and was like yo you
know walker calm down let's see what
this
what's happens here is the fluid now
he's gone right and now walker has
nothing to lose so
yeah he's gonna become more of himself
now dude and uh
bro like they're gonna throw down like
when bucky got for sure
earlier on in the episode
thank you so much for that 10 super chat
not sure if i touched on this do you
think it's weird of the police
recognized bucky
as an avenger than magic or seen his
winter soldiers still seem to be strange
uh no because because most of the world
doesn't really know too much about the
winter soldier
um what they do know about is bucky
being an avenger is saving the world
right that's a huge thing and everybody
knows the avengers saved the world and
everybody knows who was on the avengers
but magipore is the city of criminals
right so they know all about the winter
soldier
christian posada thank you so much for
that super chat do you think sam will
feel comfortable using the shield now
that has been used in public execution
probably not sam has already considered
destroying the shield so
good point
uh comic disposal super chat you've done
a few overnight appreciate it
yeah i there were some dumb things into
that uh
the mama dania parts i don't really care
about
they seem a little trying to force me to
feel some emotion for something
but i thought the dialogue between
sam and uh
carla was pretty good i thought the
wakanda fight was really good i thought
there was a lot of good parts of the
episode i actually don't think it was my
favorite episode but it was a pretty
dang good episode
um it ended super strong and i kind of
wish this one actually had a little bit
more action but
but most of what they talked about was
important i agree with you there were
some stupid parts in there that i just
didn't care for but
they were kind of fillers if that makes
sense let's see
christian masada i already got that got
that i got that i don't want to miss any
super chats
i want to make sure i didn't miss any
chris hassan power broker
is their own person just like saturday
wasn't commander oh gosh yeah
thanks for that super chat yeah that
could be true we'll see i'll
i would like maybe to see an old
character
it could be a neck i mean it's all
connected
despite i mean he just got he got
smooshed yeah i mean really just
you think about like your you think you
think it only takes like
two pounds or four pounds of pressure to
the temple to kill you so you think
about how fragile your head is and your
neck and your spinal cord in general i
mean
you know you take a hit like that from a
super soldier nonetheless
uh flying you know 50 miles an hour that
was
very violent too oh it was pretty
intense that was pretty rough i was
shocked
yeah yeah yeah it gets me high for
moonlight bro
most anticipated disney plus series
louis ramirez sings a super chat lamar
lamar served the same prep as
lewis did for soups that is until the
end of the episode
the nightmare timeline oh that's pretty
interesting take on that i kind of like
that
what uh he says lamar served the same
we're talking about the snyder cut of
course
lamar served the same purpose lewis did
for supes
that is until the end of the episode
where you saw the nightmare timeline
right yeah that's pretty good thank you
for that super chat i like that thought
um
shedrick bryant thank you for that super
chat it says message retracted
um so sorry someone said modoc is the
power broker can you imagine that'd be
wild
well there was a lot of rumors before
about him being an ant-man
three but yeah i don't know
i do think ames gonna come in at some
point though
no bro can you imagine someone said
wyatt sent in a super chat said
i think the power broker could be
kingpin oh
how about norman osborne i i would like
norman osborne
i would be inside uh somebody said oh
somebody said it in a
in my chat hold up defoe
yep
it would but i don't know if this is
this really going to tie into they
haven't really said this is going to tie
into it too much but
i mean that doesn't mean it won't
obviously right we'll see
man i this power broker thing i have to
say is like racking my brain
because i want to know if it's just like
a new person
or if it's somebody we've already seen
uh i'm
i feel like uh it would the thing is
that
i i wanna believe it's a new person like
i wanna believe it's a new character
that they're introducing
however because they still haven't shown
the character and we're four episodes in
like there's no way that they could just
throw like a new character at us
and expect us to like care about this
character hey alexandra how are you
doing welcome to the stream
yeah that that i agree with that like it
it spit well let's see episode five
like they could have shown him already
if it was a new character yeah just like
i've been building them up over the
course of the
these past couple episodes yeah yeah
it might be hard for people to get
behind that but unless it's you know
unless it's a well-known character you
know what i'm saying
so exactly like like dude if he's the
big bad of the show
like like if he's the big bad of the
show how are we gonna care about this
villain
in to to like not not even two and a
half episodes
well and that's so so let me tie in what
i'm going to say with the super chat
doom thank you so much 10
super chat so he says i like how sam
outsmarts carly in their own combo
but him using zemo's words against her
was surprising since he's been second
guessing zemo a lot
he must somewhat agree with zemo's views
i think he does and i think he agrees
with carly at the same point in time and
maybe
somehow they all come together against
whatever this power broker is
you know i think the flag smash is going
to get a little bit extreme they're
going to stop him in some way but
ultimately i think
you know is the big bad of the show the
power broker
yeah that's pretty that's i mean that's
going to be at least the
the the stepping point into the future
because yeah like we were just saying
pop and molly that's a funny name white
vision equals power broke 100
leaked footage confirmed right here
uh jimbo jones zemo will go to ross dora
milaje will never stop hunting demo
offers to fund a team to gain government
immunity his one request
name it after me yeah
i like that thank you so much i hope the
thunderbolts happen
i i i really do i really do i really
hope the thunderbolts come
topamade or tope amade i'm so sorry if i
not pronouncing that wrong given what we
know how episode five makes cry
oh that's a good point i don't know okay
hey
good point here i got a super chat i
forgot about this
uh topa mata given what we know now
how will episode 5 make us cry cuz
remember they did say that
so who dies does old man cap
come back like what
how are we gonna cry in episode five
it's a good question
bro i don't think they killed two
characters back-to-back like that
so i don't think it's going to be a
death so then does
cap come back
maybe dude alexander i don't think we're
going to be too cocky for me i think
wow alexander rosser
you want to come up here and say that to
my face
[Laughter]
you're probably two flights of stairs
away from each other
uh so people my child are saying power
broker equals hammerhead
and that would be great but the thing
with hammerhead is that he's a spiderman
villain
so i don't know about the rights with
sony's characters well that's what i was
gonna say about osborne and kingpin too
um
yeah i don't think i don't think they
have enough control over those
characters to make them
now something that i have seen in the
chat a few times is like
doom you know victor von doom maybe
something
like that i don't think i don't
i think i'm still leaning towards it's
either thunderbolt or sharon
yeah it just it it seems to make the
most sense she still
seems super yeah
jerome thank you for another super chat
do you think the next episode will be
carly going after sam's family or will
it be
an afterthought kylie will be pissed off
her friend's death
yeah but i think she separates sam from
from captain america now i
i do think she has separated them i
don't think she holds that against sam
uh i really don't barely anybody even
knows
who he is how do you know
i think there's a lot of consistent
interesting connecting points between
those characters so i'm curious what it
is specifically though
yeah sharon is is
an interesting one sharon is an
interesting one she's clearly well
connected
um yeah you know something something's
going on there with sharon for sure i
think she definitely is connected with
the power broker she obviously knows who
she is she obviously
i mean it sounds like she kind of talked
about him um
you know there's something here there's
something here for sure yo another thing
too boys
uh i think sh i i don't know if it was
sharon or bucky someone mentioned this
that uh
now madrapore is like turnt up right
like something happens that's amazing
said that
yeah yeah yeah sure like like madrapor
is is going crazy and because we all
know the ties that magikarp has to
wolverine
like dude that has to be explored
like wolverine disney plus series and
apparently apparently disney launched a
mad report website yeah yeah i saw him i
did i thought about that
magic board disney series maybe that'd
be really cool i'd love to explore all
the ins and outs of magic
high town low town yeah i hope we go
back honestly in the series i don't know
if we have time for it depends how long
these episodes are but i'd love to go
back
yeah i don't know how much more they're
going to explore it's hard and i think
we're going to get the same thing like
we did with one division
cooper dalton thank you so much for that
super chat
chadwick is a cameo that's where we cry
yeah that makes sense actually yeah
thank you so much for that
that make that makes that makes a lot of
sense
makes a ton of sense i think that's it
for sure
doom thank you for again for a super
chat bucky would have to die for me to
cry yeah
i think the chadwick thing will make
people cry but i but i get what you're
saying it would have to be something
crazy
yeah for sure we don't have to do this
we don't have to see a police
stand by freaking thing at the end of
every session that's the best part of
the show
okay okay check this out check this out
this makes sense cooper dalton thanks
for super chat chadwick is the cameo
that's why we cry they filmed before he
passed away which is true
uh yeah dude i just i can't i don't it's
not that i can't see is that i don't
think it's gonna i don't think they show
chadwick
i mean if it was filmed before i don't
think i
i don't think they're past showing him i
wouldn't be surprised if they showed him
i just didn't know if that was the
direction they're planning on going
like i don't think we see each other i
think people are overhyping this cameo
because it's just a
he was just described as a uh nathan
gibson thanks so much for that super
chat i agree with you
team walker now he's crazy homegirl
threatened kids killed a soldier
necessarily and tends to kill more she
needs to be put down she definitely
needs to be put down
i'm with zemo she's beyond reasoning
right now
she's killing innocent people stating
like that is
the language they speak like she needs
to be put down i understand why john
would go crazy and kill i'd kill for my
best friend you know
well man steve try to talk to john
walker thank you so much maverick goose
for that
uh super chat that's a top good name i'm
gonna i'm gonna guess
well old man steve try to touch john
walker it's possible i'm still on the
fence and whether or not i think he's
coming back or not
um but i i wouldn't be surprised if he
comes back i'll be super happy
but not totally surprised uh millennial
gamer thanks for that super chat power
broker is probably thunderbolt ross
us government pulling an iron man 3
mandarin to push for more american super
soldiers to fight
flag smashers that'd be pretty cool
that'd be pretty cool
and i i do think it's thunderbolt ross i
do think it's thunderbolt ross
some pym tech he's trying to get the
super soldier serum
he's trying to get his own army yeah
well i mean yeah
because the power broker and um
sorry what was this name i always forget
sony birch
no no not sony the the the guy he works
for
i always forget what do they call him
oh you the client no no it's not the
client it's the
crap what does he call him
something oh i forget all the time and
chat always reminds me
tell me who's the mysterious buyer in
ant-man of the wasp
the investor no it's not the investor
it's i'm just throwing what i think it
is
haha pratham yeah my theory did come
true it's crazy
come on come on come on guys it's
i don't remember it's like killing me
too
bit of factor thank you a better factor
thank you benefactor daniel smith thank
you everybody thank you david darko
thank you
rocket you are right in front of my
screen hey baby what you doing rock it
benefactor everybody thank you yes i
always forget it and when people say it
i'm like a freaking yes that's what it
was
yeah since they're two mysterious like
roles it would kind of make sense that
they would like you know
oh there's this mysterious role in the
mcu who is this person um
someone said someone sends in a two
dollar super chat do you think bucky
will wear the white wolf suit
bro they keep on calling him white wolf
they keep calling that he won't get a
suit
ah doom good point thanks for that super
chat ten dollars thank you so much
something else make you cry is another
cover between sam and steve before steve
dies
he is old that's why sam finally takes
shield great point my man
yeah so sorry real quick before i forget
this this is a really
good super chat combo that i just got
sent in something else that would make
me cry
is another combo combo between sam and
steve before steve
dies and that's why sam finally takes
the shield
that'd be pretty great that'd be pretty
good
that'd be pretty good that would be
perfect bro that'd be really really good
that would be perfect that would make me
cry you guys do you guys all think sam
ends up taking the shield at the end of
this do you think that's how this ends
oh one thousand percent hundred percent
hundred percent okay
sam is becoming cop we saw the toy could
the power broker
be the real mandarin giovanni trejo
thank you so much
i i don't i don't know
i don't i don't think so good good
thought great thought but i don't think
so
um dubai thank you so much can jester
hemp justin hammer be powerbroker
i would really really like that i
actually really like that character
um but i don't think so could yes
do i think so probably not uh
zom z z omg it's john
thank you so much for super chat chad
books health is getting worse around the
time of film i don't know he would have
had time filming time
that's true that's true uh i don't know
either
hold on we're fast joining us appreciate
you guys go sub to brad lambert brad our
lambert on youtube
go step to the cosmic wonder cause
let's turn it up y'all we got next week
episode five it's going to be a wild one
even more wild than episode five
two episodes turn it up like zemo
dancing in that club
bring the tissues bring the tissues boys
let's go so with that being said thank
you guys for tuning in and we'll catch
you guys next week and now
it's time to work for a living let's
work boys
good night everybody see you boys
awesome as always
glad we're back
leave zoom meeting well that was pretty
cool all right hold on i got some super
chat sorry
louis ramirez thanks for super chat sam
will be the new cap and bucky will be
white wolf
that would be pretty cool i would i
would actually like that it does seem
like he is gonna
like he is gonna pick up the white wolf
they've caught him that a few times
right so
pick up that that thing can justin
hammer be the power broker
huh i'm about to wrap it up
um jpp
three three nine three thank you so much
for super chat can i
can i just say how insane he was john
walker covering cop shield and blood
like i just finished holy hell man i'm
just in shock wasn't that cool though
let's uh let me let me pull that back up
um
let's try to get a still of that because
that really was
uh i really was pretty insane the blood
on the shield let's let's try to get a
little snapshot of that right here
show me that don't start with them again
i guess it doesn't matter
right there oh i had it hold on right
there
why are you this thing is not
here hold on
did they show it yet did they show the
blood part yet
right there oh gosh
that's a lot of blood too it's a lot of
blood
so am uh so i'm a terrible purse for
absolutely spicy walker no
and thank you for the super chat insert
cool name i think a lot of people
despise him right now
i i was i'm really pissed off at him in
this episode
but i i i can understand why he like
went crazy
and uh in a way i feel like this almost
humanized him to me
you know he felt very inferior
to steve rogers he you know that part
where he says you know where he got beat
up by the wakandans and he said
you know those weren't even super
soldiers
you know that's that's a very real
grounded part where he realizes that
he he really can't be steve rogers
physically and morally and mentally um
did i miss a super chat kyle mains
thank you so much for that final super
shot zemo and carly shares similar ideas
but zemo's way more principled oh for
sure zemo is like very calm cool
collected
in control and carly's not
carly's just i feel like very
emotionally driven
um which kind of is at the base of zemo
right
like because the whole thing with his
family and everything like that
um but you're right he's more principled
in how he's going about everything
cap5857 thank you for that super chat
could the power pro i do so many
outtakes in my video guys like you have
no idea
but could the power broker be a scroll
yes
could they be
yes it could be a scroll but i'm
wondering like who they would be
disguised as
right because it could be someone really
big
secretly a scroll
uh kyle i just got yours
i felt like i just saw some but i don't
see them anymore
oh there we go aj xyla bloody shield
would make a great funko pop
that's pretty funny i don't think they
would do that but that's pretty funny
i'm gonna agree with you i got me that
made me laugh
hate the character not the actor yeah no
i don't hate that i don't hate the actor
uh
white russell is a really really good
actor
nerds of the roundtables thank you so
much for that super chat he's a war hero
with ptsd who wants to be a good soldier
and a good cap yeah that's what
yeah and that's what i'm saying i think
this was
i think this was a very grounded episode
as far as john walker who's
like is concerned because i think
it's just him wanting to do a good job
but he's kind of realizing that he's not
steve rogers
he's not a super soldier he can't keep
up with the super soldiers and then it
was like eye opening
when he couldn't even keep up with the
uh
dormal logic
and it was just like eye opening for him
and like such a bummer like such a
letdown that like
he couldn't like he's trying to be
cap he's trying to be you know steve
rogers and he can't
um and they had that crazy good
conversation with lamar
about wanting to do the right thing
and hoping to not be evil and not fall
you know take the super soldier serum
and not go down
the wrong path you know i think
there's a lot of good in him he's just
dealing with a lot and going about it
like
the wrong way like really really really
uh power brokers jimmy wu that'd be
freaking hilarious
that'd be so funny
so i don't the only thing i don't is i
think zuma's just gonna pop back up i
don't think we're gonna have to really
like
worry about them finding zemo and i'm
pretty tired i apologize
well almost 3 a.m for me
but um i think zima's just going to pop
up because he's kind of just popped back
up before
like and was it last episode i can't
remember
when you know [ __ ] yeah it was last
episode um
he shot dr nagel left and then he came
back
you know killed a bunch of people helped
him out and drove the car
so i i think um i think he's going to
come back
see bev 1994 he went full hole blender
that's a great way to put it thank you
so much for that super chat
that's really funny yeah
something doesn't oh i guess now he does
now that he took the super soldier serum
um he kind of does have the power right
now i can see him walking to be like you
know like
pretty funny
uh big shout out to mr anderson my
moderator in the chat who uh
is doing some work right now and uh
keeping the chat clean keeping the chat
from being spam big big shout out to him
uh riffs warren do you think the
punisher could be the mystery shooter
from the last
episode is that a stretch ah i sadly
think it is kind of a stretch
uh i think they're gonna save the
punisher and other characters for like
marvel's
rated r adult content section
oh just missed super chat kevin downing
thanks for that super chat
2818 what accent was the power broker or
was that someone speaking on his behalf
let's take a look
shall we 28 18.
it's it's the power broken
play revolutionary on borrowed time
they'll go
i want the serum back or i will find no
that's the guy talking
i i could see it you see it right there
he's reading the text message
good good thought good thought maybe we
could have heard him
but yeah it's somebody else reading the
text message i miss him cam k
thanks for that super chat do you think
zemo may be on his way to yuri
or even bradley uh
no um especially considering how
far away he is from them um
i also don't know if he knows about
bradley
um
i'm trying to think if he would know
because i think that was like something
that kept like secret secret secret
um i don't think he would know
but that's a really good question uh and
thanks for the super chat i i don't
think you would know
maybe yuri but i don't think he would
know about bradley um
well alright guys i got some work to do
i'm gonna go ahead and say no
more super chats right now not that i
don't appreciate them but since there is
a little bit of a delay
i don't want to log off and miss a super
chat so let's uh let's stop the super
chaps now
super chats now so i don't miss any um
but thank you so much everybody who
shows
up for these these things are a lot of
fun and they're really really awesome i
love watching with you guys
and also kind of being able to show you
a little bit for those who don't
uh have disney plus and come watch it
and you know to be able to talk about
this with some awesome people in the
community and everything
uh it's a dream come true it's so much
fun and you guys are awesome
and uh yeah this is great and you guys
you guys make it great so thank you to
everybody who came tonight thank you for
all the super chats i super appreciate
that it helps pay the bills uh and i
really really appreciate it
um i think next episode
uh maybe it's old man cap
maybe it's chadwick i i don't know what
could make us cry
um old man cap or or chadwick that would
that would do it old man cap talking to
uh
i can't remember who sent me a super
chat talking about it but thank you
you know uh old man cap talking to sam
and sam
realizing that the shield is good
because he struggles with that right now
whether it's good or not you know
that would double do some work the
that would do some work um who knows
what's gonna happen
with uh john walker after the whole
world saw him
almost decapitate somebody and that
bloody shield i mean
i mean jeez that was that was pretty
crazy
that was pretty crazy but
lamar died and i am very sad about that
um
hope maybe he's not you know it seems
like he is but
maybe he's not uh
such a bummer because i feel like he was
genuinely a good guy
more of a good guy than john walker was
you know uh not that
i mean john walker clearly has his own
issues but i believe he wants to be a
good guy
um
but yeah like mr anderson just said
bring your tissues next time
uh we'll be here same time we start at
about
11 30 pacific time in the united states
just google if you want to kind of like
translate to your time
apparently we're gonna cry and a new
character is gonna come in maybe it's
the power broker
who knows uh i'll do lots of videos this
week on who i think is gonna be
so thank you so much to everybody who
showed up
uh again these are awesome i love you
all i'm going to do a video
i'm going to do an indian explained
i'm going to do a theory and then
saturday will be my full breakdown
because
when i try to do a full breakdown you
know in like the six hours after i've
been up all night i've noticed my brain
gets kind of groggy and i miss a few
details so
i'm gonna just do an explained video
that'll be out in uh
i don't know a few hours uh i'll
i'll post it in the morning so look out
for that
i got some theories in my head that i'm
gonna try to reiterate on the video
and then saturday will be my breakdown
so thank you so much everybody for
coming out thank you for all the super
chats you all are awesome this community
is awesome i love you all